chiefs and saints play this weekend
that's far more important as we get you
ready for week 15. couple of games on
saturday we'll talk about those coming
up but the big game on sunday kansas
city at new orleans
the question of drew brees health i
really don't think it's on the t yet i
think next friday christmas day the
viking saints game is when we'll sea
breeze or at least we're more likely to
what
how would you balance it out what
percentage does breeze have to be at in
your mind before you play him less than
a hundred over a hundred percent taysom
hill
i don't think it really matters i think
their offense is weirdly limited no
matter who's playing quarterback unless
it's jameis winston what's going on with
your boy taysom after last week because
we saw maybe the ceiling maybe the
ceiling of what he is which is
uh nice little gimmicky good in a pinch
probably not a franchise quarterback
like you've been saying
well first of all when the defense gives
up 246 rushing yards it's kind of hard
for anyone to win the game hey he's he's
three and one he's three and one and
let's see what happens this week against
the chiefs because we're going to see
how good he is or isn't this week and
and he believes he's a week in and week
out starting quarterback in the nfl the
saints believe he's a weekend and week
out starting quarterback in the nfl
and
they're not going to beat the chiefs by
holding the chiefs to 17 points they're
gonna have to score he's gonna have to
throw and and we'll see what he can do
he told me a couple of weeks ago he's
been working on his timing working with
the starting receivers when you're the
backup you don't get access to the
starting receivers they've been working
basically through this mini training
camp of getting him to the point where
he's as comfortable as he needs to be
with the receivers and they're as
comfortable as they need to be with him
this is the week this is the final exam
if he can stay within a touchdown of the
chiefs then i think he's a keeper
you know what i've noticed that that
he's been working with the receivers
because you can tell the receivers now
know that they every pass is not going
to be actually on target so they have to
come back for it or change their body
direction they're all jump balls 50 50
balls that you hope their receiver gets
to answer your first question i do think
that drew brees uh there's nothing
with the packers beating the saints
earlier in the year that's gonna be the
tiebreaker the packers uh finish the
season against the panthers i don't know
who they have oh the titans which
actually that could be tough for the
packers and then the bears
i it
it is a fine balance here because you
don't want to get drew brees hurt again
you want him to be healthy and uh ready
to go in the playoffs for this last push
and it seems like the one seed might be
you're on the outside looking in right
now so
i think you try to go with taysom hill
see what happens try to steal a win
which the saints roster is so good and
their defense is so good that i'm not
going to count them out just because
drew brees isn't playing i think that
the saints definitely could be in this
game they can win this game and to throw
everything out there mike here's a
little stat for you patrick mahomes 0-3
in his career
against the spread playing inside he's
an outdoor cat
wow wow well yeah he didn't realize it i
i like that he didn't realize he was an
outdoor cat until he had to play in the
snow for the first time in the playoffs
a couple of years ago and he realized he
really likes it so yeah i i think that
that uh that doesn't surprise me really
because he just he he moves like an
outdoor cat in those circumstances on
grass where maybe he can get a little
more of an edge over the guys chasing
him for whatever reason it's something
uncanny about the way he is that's why
it was so stunning last week when he
took that 30 yard sack you never see
that happen you always see him
being able to elude whoever it is it's
chasing him he always has that extra
little half step that things like that
don't happen you made a very
subtle
reference to jace jameis winston
so i'm going to put this to you week 1
2021
who's the starting quarterback of the
new orleans saints is it breeze is it
hill is it jameis
it's
taysom hill but i don't agree with that
peyton supposedly told jameis winston
he's going to have an opportunity to
compete to be the starter and i would
say the competition's already begun you
know what peyton said earlier this week
on the huddle and flow podcast by the
way is that um
that he promised hill
that he'd be the starter if drew brees
got hurt this year that hill's number
two period that was even before they
signed jameis winston so he made that
promise to hill he's delivered he's made
the promise to winston you'll get to
compete to be the starter when brees
leaves and i think that's one of the
reasons why winston signed with the
saints so
i i i think we we need to look at the
tea leaves that are in plain sight here
and i think there's a chance that that
winston after a full year of practice
learning the system will have an
opportunity to compete on fair footing
with taysom hill and maybe become the
starter next year i'm not closing the
door on that
hey i'm rooting for it he's a future
hall of famer for a reason so i would
love to see james whitson get
a starting job
here's patrick mahomes talking earlier
this week about facing the new orleans
saints defense
the way they're they're able to
interchange i mean those linebackers
those d linemen
db safeties malcolm jenkins all those
guys can really interchange and guard
different guys and as well as blitz and
rush the passer so it's a great
challenge kind of trying to figure out
what their game plan is for that week
who they want to put on who who they
want pressure in the quarterback and you
have to do a good job of recognizing
that quickly in order to get the ball
out of your hands and figure out a way
to have success against a really good
defense
you know the best way to defend patrick
mahomes is force him to be patient force
him to to keep the plays in the shorter
yardage range don't give him the chance
to have that big spectacular moment and
you hope that he becomes impatient and
eventually just says screw it and throws
the ball down the field and maybe you
get lucky and you pick him off and he
was picked off three times last week he
told me after the game he's not going to
change the way he plays just because he
has an interception he's going to keep
firing it he's not going to get timid
and uh yeah this should be a great game
would it be better if drew brees was
playing yes but it still should be a
very good game and and for the saints
and you mentioned it the the packers
still have to play the titans that's
next week sunday night football if the
titans beat the packers that that would
be an opening for the saints if they can
run the table to get the one seed and
the difference even though there's no
fans if you're the saints
indoor cat versus outdoor in
lambeau field in january cat that's a
huge difference so that's the stakes
that that the packers and the saints now
have in front of them
patron homes told you that personally
you talked to them
and i'm gonna mention that as much as i
can and matt casey is telling east matt
casey is pl is telling you to say those
things he did tell me that no he's not
no he's not
no he's not he's he's not said that at
all
no no
erroneous and throw it out of court
all right uh yeah is that are you are
you surprised are you trolling me are
you saying oh you've mentioned several
times and i know i know that look i know
hey the best player in the world will
talk to me on the phone yes i'm gonna
brag about it
that's pretty sick um he talks to me in
dms every now and then usually doesn't
reply whatever uh all right did you just
break some news saying that
that drew brees isn't playing on sunday
night or sunday something no i didn't
say isn't playing on so i said well you
said you better be nice
yeah i i i i'm not breaking news here
i'm just looking at the situation and
i'm assuming that they're not going to
play him this week he's still got a ways
to go sean payton told me last week can
i do that is that okay am i allowed to
say that how hard it is you know to
recover from that injury he said it's
like watching spaghetti boil you've got
all those muscles and tendons and stuff
when you try to throw a football and
they want it to be the point where he's
comfortable and and that's where look if
your backup is
i don't know pick a crappy backup one of
these guys where you could flip his last
name in his first game around and it
still makes sense okay yeah him too uh
sean mannion sean mannion his backup who
had never put on a football field
anywhere all due respect
if it's sean mannion at 100 percent then
you're going to put drew brees back out
there if his arm's hanging down you know
and he's got a rib sticking out of one
side i mean the better the backup is the
easier it is to keep the starter on ice
so i think with hill and they're
comfortable with him then
you don't play breeze until he's closer
to 100 because
you why do you want to throw him out
there if he's not ready and then he
looks like crap and then you have people
like us saying oh drew brees is washed
oh i i've been saying that before this
so i've been saying that for two years
now so don't worry about me but yeah i
know you make a good point they can win
this game with taysom hill uh running
the wildcat and throwing jump balls to
everyone
they can't no no but the point is
the point is
if brees is still diminished and i think
he is the guy had 11 broken ribs and it
was just a few weeks ago and he's 41. i
don't think he's anywhere close to a
hundred percent when you have that many
broken ribs so you arrived at taysom
hill one more week because i think drew
brees 90 percent isn't uh as good as
taysom hill at 100 and sean payton come
up with come up with a game plan come up
with a way to score points on the
chief's defense that's where payton has
made his legend over the years all right
let's move on to another game of
significance this weekend for both teams
not just
the seahawks but also the washington
football team surprisingly six and seven
holding first place in the nfc east
seahawks coming to town at nine and four
threshold question will alex smith play
this week and he's got that calf injury
ron rivera said last week that he was
held out of the second half of the 49ers
game as a precaution
now we've seen no practice wednesday no
practice thursday alex smith has said
he's not sure he's going to be able to
go
i might my gut tells me we're not going
to see alex smith on sunday it's going
to be dwayne haskins the guy who was
basically
persona known grotta with the washington
football team not that long ago
so this one's interesting because uh on
one hand
russell wilson if you look at the stats
against top 13 defenses past defenses
he's three and three on the year and not
great not great numbers i think he's
like nine and nine nine touchdowns nine
interceptions against bottom
uh you know the rest of the league he is
six and one he's racked up all his stats
guess what the washington football team
has a really good pass defense and they
get you know
they're really good at getting the
quarterback they will make him uh make
decisions quickly they will not give him
time
so the defense of the washington
football team i think can keep them in
this game and i think they can hang and
if you look at what russell wilson's
done this year he's had a good year but
against really good defenses he has
struggled you saw remember the game
against the rams he struggled um what
makes me nervous mike
is i do a thing on sunday night we
to to kind of pull back the curtain here
i'm sitting in my seat right now in the
part of my take studio we're here till
2am not a brag just a statement of fact
we're here till 2 a.m i go home i drive
back to brooklyn at 2 a.m when i get
home and i get in bed i'm still wired
from doing a show i look at the lines on
sunday night to get a gut reaction just
real quick down the line pick the game
in your head just what joe public is
thinking
and when i did that last sunday night
i've never loved a bet more than i loved
the washington football team that's a
problem
well and i've been picking against
washington every week for the last four
weeks and they just keep winning
here's what i think needs to happen and
this is a product of the conversation
sims and i have had this week about this
game the seahawks need to go back to
being the very boring
run-based be careful offense because
if washington has dwayne haskins on the
field and they don't have antonio gibson
i need to check on his status great
rookie running back and a different
offense without him too
washington's not going to produce a lot
of points with their offense they're
going to need to produce points with
their defense like last week when you
got chase young doing his walter payton
impersonation holding the football like
the loaf of bread and running to the end
zone so you can't give the washington
defense opportunity to create points you
have to be smart you have to be careful
with the ball you have to not get
russell wilson sacked five six or seven
times so i think they need to dust off
one of the old school seahawks game
plans for this and just keep it boring
keep it simple take field goals when you
can and trust that your defense is going
to be able to keep washington from
scoring because if you get too cute
that's when the washington defense is
going to swallow you up and produce a
touchdown or two you're right you're
right you just made twitter mad mike but
you're right the let rust cook maybe
there was some reasoning i think that
the pendulum needs to to find its way
right to the middle cause you know
it's crazy to say that they had a good
game plan in that playoff game against
the cowboys when they ran the ball a
million times when they used to run the
ball and take the ball out of russell
wilson's hands that was stupid when they
passed the ball 50 times that's also
stupid find that meet that balance find
the the perfect spot where you can let
russ wilson be
one of the best quarterbacks in the
league but also have that balanced
offense where he isn't asked to do
everything all the time
but that cowboys game plan
is far better than the let russ cook
approach this no that was a terrible
game
no no well it was terrible in that spot
it was terrible on that spot but that's
the game plan if if you've got dwayne
haskins and backup running backs for
washington that's a game plan that is
far better than the alternative no now i
agree with you fine middle ground you're
picking one of the other i understand i
understand yeah my point is this my
point is this if we are dealing with the
two extremes and we say the hell with
the middle
this is a game where you could get by
with what was a horrific game plan in a
playoff game against the cowboys i think
you could no against this team i think
you can
no because i because they can they could
do a good job against the run too i mean
the washington football team is a good
is a good defense a very good defense so
i think balance is the key one way or
the other and they could be in trouble
who's your coach of the year because ron
rivera's already won it twice he could
win it a third time
it was joe judge until he started daniel
jones on one leg um that was a terrific
mistake it was a horrific mistake but
he's still a better coach than john
gruden
way better coach than john gruden um
my coach of the year it's probably
either stefanski
it's between stefanski flores and tomlin
i'd probably lean
i'd probably lean to fansky right now
yeah i'm stephen i'm all in with
stefanski what yeah we're considering
the history in cleveland and how
dysfunctional it was last year without
the benefit of an off-season program to
come in and turn that thing around the
way that he has i think it's been
incredible but i think ron rivera if
they win the division
uh you have to take ron rivera seriously
because even more dysfunction this year
in washington than in cleveland going
into the season speaking of cleveland
the browns nine and four prime time on
nbc at the new york giants joe judging
company five and eight they haven't let
us know whether or not daniel jones will
be playing on one leg or colt mccoy will
be playing on two legs uh and and
they they haven't even had a chance to
fully evaluate jones he's got the
hamstring he's got an ankle injury now
i'm not going to be surprised if we see
colt mccoy i like the fact that joe
judge is keeping it close to his vest
you know coaches
with with far more experience than judge
aren't nearly good enough at taking
advantage
of the potential for creating
uncertainty that falls into your lap
yeah you'd rather your quarterback not
be injured but if he is let's take full
advantage of keeping the other team
guessing which is exactly what joe judge
is doing
the freddy kitchen's revenge game i'm
excited for this sunday night game um so
to me this game is pretty simple in that
if the giants can can
just be
i'm not even average on offense they
could be just a touch below average what
you know that game against the cardinals
on sunday
i looked up every single time i looked
up the giants were at third and nine on
their own 15 yard line like they weren't
going forward at all they gave their
defense no chance the giants defense is
a good unit and if they give the giant
if the giants offense can give their
defense just a little bit of breathing
room i think giants can win this game
because the key to to beating the browns
is to get pressure on baker mayfield get
him a little bit frantic and i think the
giants have that ability i i think this
game will be a tight game
and all you need is colt mccoy to be
just a little bit you know he's got to
be an average quarterback for one night
and the giants can win this game
with baker mayfield when they beat the
titans i regretted not seeing that the
titans don't have the pass rush that can
cause baker mayfield to wilt a little
bit get a little kirk cousins e there's
a there's a thread there from baker
mayfield to kirk cousins when
everything's going fine you can get it
done when it starts to crumble you can't
get it done you can't run away from
pressure you can't improvise when you
have to when you have to go off schedule
but then last week against the ravens i
mean the ravens have a real pass rush
they were chasing him around he he he
just had a spring in his step and he he
said wednesday that when he plays better
with confidence and i think it's a
snowball effect he's getting more
confidence he's playing better which
leads him more confidence which means
he's playing better first back-to-back
300-yard games of his career he's been
phenomenal since the buy he explained
this week that during that buy after the
loss to the raiders 16-6 their first
game without otto beckham jr that was
really their chance to take a breath and
evaluate themselves without the benefit
of pre-season without the benefit of an
off-season program with a new head coach
and new systems and they learned a lot
about what they need to do on offense
during the bye week and this is the
product of it so i i just i think what
the browns did on
monday night you know we've talked about
how the raiders acted like they won a
super bowl in playing the chiefs close
and the hail murray game what it did to
the cardinals i really see what happened
monday night and especially the way that
stefanski reacted to it saying there's
no moral victories whatever the case may
be i think that that becomes
something that propels the browns even
though they lost the game and that's why
i think we're going to win tonight and
that's why i think they're going to run
the table and that's why i think they're
going to be a tough team to beat in
january and you know for all those
browns fans out there that have been
suffering through crap for the last 20
years i hope that they get something i
don't know that they're look they're not
going to beat the chiefs i i think that
i think it's going to be the chiefs
versus somebody in the nfc that's the
super bowl chiefs versus somebody
but the browns i think at least
can make some noise and if they get the
ravens or the steelers again in the
playoffs
uh you know who who knows what happens
all right i i you've changed my opinion
you changed my opinion about this game
i'll take the browns i think the browns
are all right good
uh
you've already made you already made
your bet on the giants though so it's
too late no
well i mean
when do you lock in your bet
when do you make your best throughout
the week but the it could be the browns
to win and the giants to cover there's
enough there's enough room there five
and a half four and a half
yeah i i like the browns to win and to
cover but we'll see what happens that's
the thing nobody ever nobody ever comes
back and throws it in your face when you
get uh when you get it wrong just your
bookie
all right
what it doesn't happen no they don't
throw it in no look when you're picking
16 games i mean if you get more than
half of them right yeah well i mean
other than teams other than team no well
what other than teams your swear
mentions are a lot different than mine
my friend because i get it throughout my
face all the time
the only the only entity on twitter that
that throws it in your face is the team
social media account of the team that
was so bad
that you trust that they're going to
continue to be bad and they somehow
stumble their way into an upset and they
puff out their chest
like there's some secret super bowl
contender that nobody knew about so
other than that i don't maybe those are
the only ones i pay attention to i'm so
used to getting crap in my mentions i
ignore it i just ignore it thicken your
skin and and ignore the haters let's
take a break wait speaking i got no
problem with it but i get it all the
time my mentions are all your idiot you
pick you pick the wrong you pick the
wrong games your mentions are florida
stop trying to cancel football i think
that's fair
yeah yeah that's oh and i failed i've
been trying for my quest
to be unemployed
has failed
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports